un journal ça y est je crois que je suis
à bout il paraît que ce qui ne nous tue
pas nous rend plus forts mais pour
l'instant il ya quand même beaucoup de
choses qui ne m'ont pas tué et pourtant
je ne soulève pas bien lourd à la salle
peut-on mourir de phobies administrative
quelle triste sort cela ferait quoi une
pauvre petite ligne dans la rubrique
fait divers d'un quotidien gratuit merci
mais j'aspire quand même à mieux
j'aimerais qu'il existe un bouton reset
quelque part pour recommencer ma vie
pour laisser tous mes problèmes derrière
moi repartir à zéro sans expérience
pouvoir faire d'autres choix
alors certes je ne pourrais pas avoir la
certitude que tout serait mieux après je
pourrais me retrouver sans eau ni
électricité et avec des toilettes sèches
c'est vrai c'est un risque mais au moins
je n'aurai pas de factures à payer dans
les temps je pourrais me retrouver agent
administratif dans un centre des impôts
explique aux gens comme moi pourquoi
c'est important de les renvoyer le
formulaire cerfa des 1040 trois mois la
date butoir et ce serait terrible c'est
vrai mais il me suffirait d'appuyer sur
mon bouton reset et peut être qu'enfin
je serai sur la scène du dolby theater à
recevoir un oscar tant méritée j'en
reviens pas parce que juste d'être
nominé c'était déjà un honneur un prix
nobel un oscar la même année c'est
commence à faire beaucoup mais maman je
sais pas où tu es merci à tous c'est
grâce à vous donc c'est pour vous tout
ça et puis j'aurai quelqu'un pour gérer
la paperasse à ma place
et si pour une raison obscure ma
carrière se mettaient à battre de l aile
eh bien je n'aurai qu'à appuyer sur mon
bouton reset et cher journal bon ben ça
y est je crois que je suis à bout il
paraît que ce qui ne nous tue pas nous
rend plus forts et non non non non non
bah quoi non mais on a déjà dit ça
[Musique]
waouh
je